phew so a lot of you been asking me how I'm doing since the whole
I didn't realize that there was some Wick and Dorito cult that
well they're talking about this
I'm in Arizona see the cactuses
fighting for reproductive rights
trying to talk to any person that I can
to try and keep this country safe for all of us
the right wing media ecosystem thrives on concocting fake scandals like this
in order to keep their audiences engaged
and enslamed
so whether it's about feminist women or Haitian immigrants eating pets
it's all meant to distract and divide us
and these fabrications become real just because they keep talking about them
there are forces who want to divide us
and one of them is running for president
a man who just threatened to use the military against US citizens
to fight the enemy from within
I don't see anybody in this country as Miami
but the man running for president is banking on us doing that
and I've now seen firsthand how the right wing machine fuels that division
in order to help him we cannot afford to let them tear us apart
women are dying from abortion bans
people can afford their groceries because of price gouging
and two hurricanes just decimated people's homes
we need real solutions not division
so let's take all of this energy and put it into the next two weeks
I know this is a really close election okay
I know that
that feels very terrifying
but here's why that's exciting
every single little thing that you do matters okay
it means that this is gonna come down to a few votes
which means that if you can impact or influence one person's vote
you are making a really big difference
every single small thing that you do
could be the tipping point that decides who gets the keys to the White House
let's take all of this energy
put it into talking to each other
deep canvassing day canvassing
the more we work together
the less they can chip away at our future
sorry I had to
I had to do it I love you bye